only on CBS this morning Dylan Farrow is
speaking for the very first time on TV
about her sexual assault allegations
against her adoptive father actor and
director Woody Allen at the age of seven
Dylan told her mother actress Mia Farrow
that Allen had molested her Allen has
always denied the allegations Dylan
Farrow has stood by her story for more
than two decades now she first went
public back in 2014 with an open letter
in The New York Times and now right here
on CBS this morning
we spoke with Farrow at her Connecticut
home on Monday where she went into
detail about what allegedly happened one
August morning I want to show my face
and tell my story I want to speak out
literally Dylan Farrow is 32 and has
been married for almost eight years
she's a mother of a 16 month old girl
and she's still carrying the emotional
scars she says she got at the hands of
her father I loved my father I respected
him he was my hero and that doesn't
obviously take away from what he did but
it does make the betrayal and the hurt
that much more intense let's go to
August 4th 1992 and if you could tell us
what happened that day I was taken to a
small attic crawlspace in my mother's
country house in Connecticut by my
father he instructed me to lay down on
my stomach and play with my brother's
toy train that was set up and he sat
behind me in the doorway and as I played
with the toy train I was sexually
assaulted as a seven year old I would
say I would have said he touched my
private parts
hmm okay okay which I did say all right
all right as a 32 year old he touched my
labia my vulva with his finger where was
your mother she went shopping at
and then after you told her what
happened she was upset my first impulse
was that I had done something wrong
Mia Farrow took Dylan to the
pediatrician but when the doctor asked
her where she had been touched the
little girl pointed to her shoulder she
said why didn't you tell the doctor what
you told me and I told her that I was
embarrassed and then we went back in you
went back in and then you told him and I
told the doctor the same thing that you
had told your mother yes Alan had
suggested that Dylan changed her story
because she had been coached by her
mother months earlier Mia had found in
his apartment nude pictures of her
daughter Sooni whom she had adopted
during an earlier marriage
Alan confessed to an affair with SUNY
the two remain a couple to this day
married for more than 20 years you could
see why he might make that claim he
would say that she was filled with rage
after his affair with SUNY had been
discovered and that she was out for
revenge and full of rage
and what I don't understand is how is
this crazy story of me being brainwashed
and coached more believable than what
I'm saying about being sexually
assaulted by my father because your
mother was very angry so that she would
try to coach you and try to get you to
turn against your father
except every step of the way my mother
has only encouraged me to tell the truth
she has never coached me I wanted to
play a clip from 60 minutes an interview
that he did at the time where he was
asked about that incident are you okay
with looking at it okay a very bitter
acrimonious custody fight drive up to
Connecticut where nobody likes me now as
I'm at the house full of enemies I mean
Mia was so enraged at me and and she had
gotten all the kids to to be angry at me
that I'm gonna drive up there and
suddenly on visitation pick this moment
in my life to become a child molester
it's just it's just incredible I could
if I wanted to be child molester I had
the opportunities in the past I could
have quietly made it a custody
settlement with me in some way and done
it in the future you know it's so insane
what do you say to that I'm really sorry
don't apologize don't apologize I
thought I could handle it I are you
crying because of what he said or seeing
him what is upsetting you
he's playing and he's been lying for so
long and it is difficult for me to see
him and to hear his voice I'm sorry Alan
had adopted Dillon and her 13 year old
brother Moses the previous December the
couple also had a younger son Ronan but
as Mia Farrow's boyfriend Alan had been
a part of Dillon's life since she was a
baby Dylan says that the incident in the
Attic wasn't the only time his behavior
had been inappropriate what would he do
he would follow me around
he was always touching me cuddling me
and if I ever said you know like I want
to go off by myself he wouldn't let me
some could say that's a very doting and
loving father except he wasn't this way
with Ronan what else would he do he
often asked me to get into bed with him
when he had only his underwear on and
sometimes when only I had my underwear
on Woody Allen was never charged with a
crime in this case both New York state
child welfare investigators and a report
by the Yale New Haven Hospital found
that the abuse did not happen the
Connecticut state prosecutor on the case
Frank Mako questioned the Yale New Haven
reports credibility saying there was
probable cause to charge alan but he
thought Dylan was too fragile to face a
celebrity trial do you wish that they
would have gone ahead and filed the
charges because then you would have to
take in the stand
you know honestly yes I do wish that
they had you know even if I'm just
speaking in retrospect I was already
traumatized here's the thing I mean
outside of a court of law we do know
what happened in the Attic on that day I
just told you
we reached out to former Connecticut
prosecutor Frank Mako earlier this week
he tells us that in his experience there
was no manipulation by Mia Farrow he
adds nothing in the State Police
investigation indicated that Dylan was
in any way being controlled or
manipulated by her mother in a statement
to CBS this morning Woody Allen writes
in part even though the Farrell family
is cynically using the opportunity
afforded by the times of movement to
repeat this discredited allegation that
does not make it any more true today
than it was in the past
I never molested my daughter now you can
read his full statement at CBS s Morning
Calm it's a very lengthy statement he
has a response to what she's saying
today you know I remember reading her
her op-ed but I would hear her tell the
story so painful clearly her and to see
her adoptive father again and you know
what Nora that is why she wanted to do a
TV interview because she said sometimes
when you just see the written words it
doesn't translate she wanted people to
see how strongly she felt about it how
pain she is bite and she thought that
maybe it was lost in translation because
so many people did not believe her well
see you said it best I thought yesterday
John when he said maybe people are
listening with new ears now yeah and is
that is that what she hopes or is this
she hopes that now she's been able to
tell it it helps her heal well you know
I think she just wants to tell her story
and let people make their own decision I
think that's where she is at this point
we will have part two of our
conversation with Dylan Farrell in our
next hour she tells us about the support
she's received in Hollywood and the
advice she plans to give her own young
daughter that's ahead